omicronwelle gestörte Lieferketten hohe
Ölpreise just how much the fat Race
intertrace nextm one the ussion
und ich habe ziemlich genau vor sechs
Monaten 40.000 € investiert nice warum
ich über diese Entscheidung aber
trotzdem happy bin wie ich in der Zeit
weiter investiert habe wo mein Portfolio
gerade steht und wie ich in den nächsten
Monaten weiter investiere erfahrt ihr in
diesem Video ach ja bevor sie losgeht
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
im November kommen hier zehn Videos zu
sevenvers World Staffel 2 behind the
scenes die wir über die letzten vier
Wochen mit dem gesamten Team produziert
haben ich war die ganze Zeit dabei die
Kamera lief im Hintergrund die ganze
Zeit und es wird richtig krass das
größte Projekt jemals auf meinem Kanal
vergesst also nicht zu abonnieren und
jetzt viel Spaß mit dem Video oh boy
kurzer Rückblick in den Kreislauf der
Scheiße es ist Krieg politische Unruhen
Sanktionen das Geld wird weniger Wert
also Inflation der Leitzins wurde
angehoben all das trägt dazu bei dass es
dem Markt gerade nicht besonders gut
geht und vor allem es geht der
Gesellschaft nicht besonders gut wie
kommen wir durch den Winter wie teuer
wird die Energie und so weiter die Angst
ist gerade einfach super hoch was man
auch im vielen greet-index sieht der
probiert genau das abzubilden hat man es
geschafft über die letzten Jahre sich
eine Notgroschen anzueignen wie es
finanz ist unser König über die letzten
Jahre immer gepredigt hat ging das
vielleicht nicht hatte man für Leute zu
sorgen hat meine Familie muss man Leute
pflegen und hat dadurch einfach nicht
geschafft Kohle wegzubekommen all das
ist ein riesengroßes politisches Thema
super viele Facetten super kleinen
teilig was ich zum einen erstmal gar
nicht verstehe und zum anderen sehe ich
mich nicht in der Position dass in
irgendeiner Weise zu bewerten oder
einzuschätzen weil ich gar nicht alle
Informationen habe heute geht es um
meine Aktien meine Investments der
letzten sechs Monate und wie ich in den
nächsten Monaten gerne damit
weitermachen will und so viel kann ich
sagen es sieht nicht besonders rosig aus
oder vielleicht doch für die Leute die
bereits investiert sind sind fallende
Aktienkurse natürlich der Horror die
Aktie hat 100 € gekostet jetzt kostet
sie nur noch 70 wir haben 30% verloren
absolute Scheiße für die Leute die
allerdings noch nicht investiert sind
ist es natürlich eine unheimlich gute
Einstiegschance es fühlt sich fast an
wie so ein Sommerschlussverkauf oh sie
kostet nur noch 70 von einem Monat hat
sie noch 100 gekostet das bedeutet man
kommt einfach günstiger rein man kann
günstiger dabei sein kurzer Rückblick
investiert habe ich damals 40.000 Euro
10.000 Euro in Gold 10.000 Euro in
Krypto 10.000 € in ETF und 10.000 Euro
in eine Luxusuhr uhrklammern wir erstmal
aus da gibt es ein paar Besonderheiten
insgesamt also 30.000 Euro zum Start im
Portfolio gehabt und daraus wären hätte
ich nicht umgeschichtet heute
25.346 Euro also -15% geworden ich habe
aber um geschichtet ich habe nachgekauft
ich habe Dinge verkauft und dafür neue
Sachen gekauft und deswegen sieht mein
Portfolio jetzt so aus insgesamt habe
ich ca 65.000 Euro investiert und aus
diesen 65.000 Euro sind
58.819 Euro geworden also ein Verlust
von 10,41 Prozent was immer noch super
krass ist aber natürlich deutlich besser
als die 15% hätte ich nicht
umgeschichtet also was habe ich genau
getan schon anderthalb Monate nachdem
das Video online ging habe ich mich dazu
entschieden dass ich Gold nicht so
hartgewichten bin ich wollte fürs Videos
super einfach haben zehn da zehn da zehn
da zehn da wusste aber das ist
wahrscheinlich nicht so bleiben wird ich
habe eine Wertanlage in meiner Uhr eine
reelle Wertanlage also Materialwert
einen handwerklichen Wert und einfach
etwas wirklich wert beständiges was
weniger ein Investment und mehr eine
Wertanlage ist und deswegen habe ich das
Gold nicht mehr so richtig gesehen also
habe ich es mit 523 Euro im Plus
verkauft und es komplett umgeschichtet
in MSCI World und MSCI imagine markets
wodurch ich dann bei 20.000 Euro in ETF
und 10.000 Euro in Krypto war investiert
habe ich natürlich wie immer über mein
lieblingsbroker und Partner scalable
capital scalable capital ist nicht nur
mein persönlicher Broker sondern auch
finanzfluss Testsieger ihr könnt direkt
mobil übers Handy oder eine Desktop
Version super einfach in Aktien Krypto
ETF und viele weitere Finanzprodukte
investieren die Account Erstellung
dauert nur wenige Minuten es ist
komplett kostenlos und ihr könnt schon
ab einem Euro in Aktien Krypto und
ETF-Sparpläne investieren mit einer
Trading Flatrate fallen die eh schon
geringen Ordergebühren von 99 Cent dann
auch noch weg wenn ihr also anfangen
wollt zu investieren einen neuen Broker
sucht oder euch einfach mal mit der App
vertraut machen wollt dann tut das über
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
und ladet euch scalable capital herunter
und wie immer macht es denn eigenen
Tempo macht es wirklich nur mit Geld
dass ihr verlieren könnt guckt euch
finanzfluss Videos an und ganz wichtig
sammelt einfach Informationen bevor ihr
investiert wenn ihr aber wirklich Geld
investieren wollt dann kann es sehr gut
sein dass gelbe capital der richtige
Broker für euch ist ist es ein deutsches
Unternehmen ist eine Deutsche Bank
dahinter und es ist der finanzfluss
Broker Testsieger alle Links dazu der
Broker Vergleich und so weiter auch in
der Videobeschreibung klickt auf den
ersten Link checkt das aus und jetzt
viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video dafür
nehmen wir als Beispiel mal den Chart
vom MSCI World den Performance Chart
hier in Parkett wo ich meinen gesamtes
Portfolio abbildet ganz links das
anfangsinvestment alles sieht wunderbar
aus wir machen ordentlich wir machen
ordentlich Kohle der Kurs steigt einfach
es ist alles grün wunderbar und als es
das erste Mal von dieser Hochphase ein
bisschen dropped kaufe ich nach das
droppt weiter ich kaufe nach und dann
geht's hier direkt in den richtig roten
Bereich und ihr seht wo der Kurs mit am
niedrigsten ist probiere ich zu timen
und zu kaufen und quasi den Weg runter
schon mitzunehmen mit dem Kauf davor und
genau das habe ich Kommentaren und werde
ich in den nächsten Monaten weiter tun
wollen und nicht nur bei MSCI World
sondern auch bei imagin markets das ist
das einzige was ich weiter besparen
möchte ich will keine neue Luxusuhr ich
möchte nicht mehr Krypto ich möchte
einfach nur weiter in ETFs investieren
und genau hier kommt das zum Tragen was
ich und ganz viele andere auch immer
gesagt haben investiert wirklich nur mit
Geld dass ihr wirklich verlieren könnt
in solchen Situationen ist es gut
Bargeldreserven zu haben es ist gut
sicher sein zu können alles alle mieten
alle
Energiepreiserhöhungen zahlen zu können
und genau dafür ist dieses Notgroschen
Konto einfach unheimlich wichtig es
bringt einfach nichts sich selber und
sein Lebensstandard für irgendwelche
potenziellen Kursgewinne in Gefahr zu
bringen und ganz wichtig ist auch noch
mal zu verstehen man verdient kein Geld
als Laie am Aktienmarkt also du und ich
für uns ist es dafür da um Geld beiseite
zu schaffen um das Geld für sich selber
über Jahre und Jahrzehnte arbeiten zu
lassen wir sind keine Investoren wir
sind keine Trader und es funktioniert
einfach nicht wir werden mit dem
Aktienmarkt nicht reich wir schaffen
damit Geld beiseite vielleicht haben wir
irgendwie Glück mit unserem großen
Freund dem Zinseszins über Jahre und
Jahrzehnte reicht zu werden short time
verdienen wir damit de facto kein Geld
es ist einfach so die Aktien sind mit
Abstand mein lieblingsinvestment ich
kann jeden Tag verfolgen was abgeht und
das ist einfach wirklich wie so ein
Hobby geworden ein ganz besonderes
Investment oder die Wertanlage ist aber
tatsächlich meine Uhr gekauft habe ich
eine Rolex Submariner 14060 das ist ein
ganz besonderes Modell war auch das
erste Modell das Mark Gebauer damals
gekauft hat und bezahlt habe ich unter
12.000 €, ich glaube
11.750 mittlerweile ist das günstigste
Modell was man im deutschen Markt online
findet ohne box und Papiere die
tatsächlich bei mir dabei sind also ich
habe einen vollständiger Reset 13.450 €,
ich würde also davon ausgehen dass meine
Uhr irgendwo so bei 14.000 € liegt das
bedeutet wir haben ein bisschen mehr als
2000 Euro plus gemacht mega geil ist
darum geht es mir aber tatsächlich bei
der Uhr nicht mehr ich trage die Uhr
mittlerweile fast täglich ich erfreue
mich super krass daran ich freue mich
daran die aufzuziehen die einzustellen
die anzulegen sie aktiv nicht anzuziehen
um mir den Spaß damit beizubehalten und
sie nach ein paar Tagen zu irgendwas
besonderem wieder anzuziehen und ich mag
die Sicherheit die sie mir gibt
überhaupt nicht im Sinne von oh schau
mich an ich bin so selbstsicher weil ich
die Uhr anhabe sondern vielmehr im Sinne
von das hier ist ein Wert erhaltenes
Objekt das sich so nah bei mir trage
dass das mich in Krisensituationen
potenziell absichert egal wo ich mit
dieser Uhr hinreisen würde mir geht's
richtig schlecht und ich muss irgendwie
schnell nach Hause ich kriege die fast
überall verkauft ich habe absolut keine
Pläne diese Uhr jemals abzugeben und sie
zu verkaufen und den Aktien
umzuschichten oder irgendwas dieses Ding
bleibt meine Sicherheit für eh und je
bis ich es tatsächlich brauche oder ich
schaffe sie irgendwann weiterzugeben es
gibt allerdings Luxusgüter in meinem
Leben bei denen ich ziemlich stark am
überlegen bin ob ich sie verkaufe um das
Geld in Aktien umzuschichten
beispielsweise meinen Tesla vielleicht
muss er gehen damit ich mehr MSCI World
und mehr MSCI emergen markets kaufen
kann damit ich liquide bin um das in den
nächsten Monaten mitzunehmen
einzusteigen und muss dann vielleicht
auf Luxus in meinem Alltag verzichten
ich werde weniger entspannt reisen ich
werde weniger entspannt Sachen
transportieren können und ich liebe das
Auto es ist aber ein Level an Luxus den
ich garantiert so nicht brauche und
natürlich blicke ich in dem Moment auch
wehmütig in mein Portfolio und es ist
schwierig mit anzusehen ich freue mich
aber doppelt langfristig auf alles das
was kommen mag und das hier ist einfach
defaktor ein günstiger Einstieg und es
wird vielleicht auch noch günstiger wie
auch immer ich habe keine Glaskugel ich
hoffe euch hat das Video gefallen wenn
ja lasst gerne ein Like da vergesst
nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren ich freue
mich riesig auf sein Vers 2 Staffel 2
behalten das Teams im November das wird
ein Riesenfest wir sitzen mit drei
kattern schon im das wird das größte
Projekt jemals auf meinem Kanal